today we're making a boola chera also
known as creamy rice and chicken this
easy one pot recipe is a Cuban comfort
food you'll keep going back to we're
going to start with our Sofrito which is
bell peppers onion and garlic lightly
sauteed in olive oil with some
Sasa this is the base of all great
Caribbean dishes in my opinion you're
then going to add tomato sauce cooking
wine and your chicken thighs let this
cook for about 15 minutes over low
medium heat now to this PO add your rice
and simmer over low heat for 15 minutes
covered and now right at the end when
it's almost finished add in your room
temperature beer which is our family
trick to get the perfect arok boo
consistency this dish is creamy
comforting and feels like a big hug and
the best part is that you only have one
pot to
clean